heartbreak for England as they crash out
of the World Cup captain Harry Kane
missed a penalty against France to take
the match into extra time the game has
just ended 2-1 the latest pictures are
from Croydon the moment that the game
actually came to an end
[Music]
or just uh despair there I think a
stunned silence that it's actually
over we'll take a look at the picture in
Manchester and fans there gathering for
the game
[Music]
to great disappointment
[Music]
[Applause]
but that is the breaking news that
England had been knocked out of the
World Cup by France the final score 2-1
and Harry Kane missing that second
penalty the first he took and
successfully found the back of the net
but then
unfortunately went straight over the bar
[Music]
and there's been another upset and a
historic result at the World Cup in the
third quarter final Morocco dumped
Portugal out of the tournament they
become the first African nation to make
it to the World Cup semi-finals Morocco
will play France Sky's Alistair bunkel
is in Qatar
the Water Resort in Morocco really the
Underdog Story of this tournament they
had that shock result against Spain in
the last 16 they came up against
Portugal tonight and they won just the
single goal coming before half-time but
they hung on they played deep Portugal
pressed them but they hung on for the
win and this fan Park in the center of
Doha absolutely erupted just have a look
around at the scenes now with it being
the first World Cup ever held in the
Middle East and Morocco the final Arab
team left in the tournament they have
become the host Nations team to follow
thousands of Morocco fans have flown in
here as well to watch the match and
support their sides but the qataris have
taken them on and when the goal went in
and when the final whistle went this
place went crazy it will be crazy across
Qatar tonight as well they of course are
now in the semi-final the first African
seem to reach the World Cup semi-final
the first Arab team to win the World Cup
semi-final they are making history as
they go but also work tonight on
Cristiano Ronaldo one of the world's
greatest players of all time His World
Cup is over we won't see him on this
stage ever again he walked off the pitch
at the end of the match in tears down
the tunnel it's over for the Portuguese
player it's over for Portugal but
Morocco
there you go on and they will face
either England or France in the
semi-finals and you know what they'll be
confident they can go all the way to the
final now